uh let's bring you breaking news now we
have had an update on government plans
the plans to use a modified barge to
house up to 500 Asylum Seekers these
plans have been talked about for the
last few days we're getting official
confirmation now from the government
that this is going to happen let's bring
in our political correspondent Amanda
acass she's been following this closely
from Westminster uh so what's new Amanda
yes so we have finally this afternoon
got the official confirmation as you say
that the government has done a deal to
lease this um very large barge it's
known as the Bibi Stockholm it has more
than 200 ensuite cabins on board it can
house more than 500 or so migrants and
it's going to be docked in Portland in
Dorset now we've got a statement from
the home office who say that they are
going to explore the use of other
vessels vessels as well to accommodate
migrants they say it will reduce the
Reliance on expensive hotels and deliver
a more orderly cost effective and
sustainable Asylum accommodation system
now the government ministers have
repeatedly been telling us that the cost
of hotels is running at around 6 million
pounds a day it's thought that the
government currently is housing around
50 000 Asylum seekers in hotels uh this
year anyway so obviously these 500
people that will be um living on board
this this vessel is is is kind of
dwarfed in comparison but the cost uh we
don't know the exact details of the cost
but they're saying it will be cheaper
um we're told it's just for single adult
males
um it will provide basic functional
accommodation and Healthcare provision
catering facilities and 24 7 Security in
place on board to minimize the
disruption to local communities now
that's quite important because already
since the idea of this has been reported
in the last few days there's been a huge
amount of opposition from local
community down in Portland in Dorset so
the local MP for example who is a
conservative Richard Drax has been very
outspoken about it saying he along with
the council and the police and crime
commissioner other local groups are
looking at the possibility of legal
action against the government on various
grounds The Strain on local services but
also the impact this will have on the
all-important tourism history on the
Jurassic coat on the Jurassic Coast
having 500 young mainly single men
accommodated there all of a sudden is
obviously going to have quite an impact
on a relatively small community now it's
interesting to note that this particular
vessel was previously used in the
Netherlands to house Asylum Seekers now
when it was there it was actually
inspected and and criticized as being an
aggressive and oppressive environment we
understand it has been
um refurbished since then the government
actually in their release talk about the
fact it was previously used in other
places in Europe they say it's important
to save taxpayers money and to prevent
the UK becoming a magnet magnets for
Asylum Shoppers in Europe so this is the
government's arguments that they don't
want the use of Hotel accommodation
attracting people to the UK migrant
Charities obviously disagree with that
quite strongly but that's part of the
government's argument that they want to
create accommodation that will be a
deterrent although they do say
accommodation all accommodation will
meet on legal obligations we'll work
closely with the local community to
address their concerns including through
financial support now obviously the
government have come a Cropper with some
of the accommodation they've provided
for Asylum Seekers before notably in the
processing center Napier Barracks down
in folkestone previously subject to a
number of legal challenges because of
the standard of accommodation there
although that was never designed for
people to stay there in the long term
now they've also got a quote from the
chief executive of Portland Port who
says we're keen to play our part in the
National effort to house some of the
thousands of people needing
accommodation he's saying he wants to
encourage everyone in the community to
approach this with an open mind and help
us show other areas just how successful
this type of initiative can be both for
migrants and the local community they
say there'll be close cooperation with
local agencies particularly including
health services and Emergency Services
I think that's an interesting warning
shot I guess back to the council and
local MP who are obviously very
concerned about this the government also
says that this uh this vessel is going
to be operational for at least 18 months
um which obviously is quite a long
period of time but we don't know exactly
how quickly it's going to arrive we
understand that it's currently in Italy
it will need to be towed because of the
nature of the vessel is it's a Bard so
it doesn't have its own steam as it were
but given the prospect of a legal
challenge which is also something which
is on the cards for the other plans the
government has in place to develop new
deterrent style accommodation for Asylum
Seekers by redeveloping two disused RAF
bases in Lincolnshire and Essex as well
as this former open prison in Bex Hill
local authorities there also say that
they're looking carefully at this uh
looking at the prospect of legal action
in Lincolnshire and Essex a lot of
criticism from some of their local Tory
MPS including some big names foreign
secretary James cleverley pretty Patel
the former Home Secretary
um the rail Minister Hugh Merriman not
happy about it either down in Bex Hill
particularly so the government have put
their statement of intent on the table
now they're saying we do have a vessel
we're looking at getting other vessels
in future too we think this is the
answer or part of the answer to this
situation but I think they're going to
face a lot of opposition okay Amanda
acasser with the latest there thank you
the home office confirming it has leased
a barge to accommodate around 500
migrants in Portland Dorset